So today, we've talked about explanation-based learning,
a type of learning where we learn new connections between existing concepts.
We first talked about our concept space.
A space of information that enables us to draw inferences and
connections about existing concepts. We then talked about how prior knowledge is
mapped onto this concept space for new reasoning. Then we talked about how we
may abstract over prior knowledge to discern transferable nuggets. And how we
might then transfer those nuggets onto the new problem we encounter. Next time,
we'll expand on this idea of transfer to talk about analogical reasoning,
which is inherently transfer-based. Explanation-based learning will also come up
significantly in learning about correcting mistakes and
in diagnosis. So feel free to jump ahead into those lessons,
if you're interested in continuing with this example.